Ah, ça fait du bien quand ça sort !
Quand on peut le faire ensemble, c’est encore
mieux !
Hum… ça va un peu loin là, non ? Il a
vraiment mérité, ça ?
Manuel Valls était Premier ministre, pas
président - mais le sens de l’acte est
le même.
Je vais vous montrer pourquoi il est bon de
haïr le président.
Vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
la chaîne qui parle du meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.
Bonjour, je suis Romain, le créateur du site
1000 idées de culture générale et coauteur
du manuel du même nom.
Je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du concept
de bouc émissaire de René Girard, qui est
un de mes auteurs préférés.
Dans Le bouc émissaire, mais aussi dans d’autres
livres, il montre que les groupes humains
ont tendance à polariser la culpabilité
de leurs problèmes sur un seul individu ou
une seule chose, quand bien même les phénomènes
réels ont généralement des causes multiples.
Mais paradoxalement, ce mécanisme injuste
serait bénéfique.
Alors, pourquoi est-ce qu’il serait bon
de haïr le président ?
Le président est un bouc émissaire dans
la mesure où on lui fait porter la responsabilité
de maux dont il n’est en réalité que partiellement,
voire pas du tout responsable.
En pratique, le pouvoir du président est
limité ; il ne peut pas tout, loin de là,
et de multiples causes, sur lesquelles il
n’a aucune prise, peuvent expliquer les
problèmes d’un pays : la conjoncture, la
culture, l’héritage historique, les systèmes
politique et administratif, etc.
Mais c’est plus simple de désigner un unique
coupable, le bouc émissaire.
Le bouc émissaire, ça vient de l’Ancien
Testament, où Dieu demande à Moïse de faire
porter les péchés d'Israël par un bouc.
Là il n’y a aucun doute sur l’innocence
du bouc !
Pour René Girard, le bouc émissaire est
un mécanisme social universel : dès lors
qu’un groupe se constitue, tous ses membres
sont susceptibles de faire reposer la responsabilité
des maux du groupe sur l’un d’entre eux.
Alors, le président est peut-être le bouc
émissaire de la nation, mais je n’ai pas
expliqué en quoi ça serait une bonne chose.
Dans la perspective de la théorie du bouc
émissaire, il est bon de haïr le président
parce que cela permet d’expulser la violence,
verbale et même physique, qui sévit entre
les individus à l’intérieur de la nation.
Toutes les pulsions de violence sont dirigées
et expulsées vers une seule figure, et comme
ça le potentiel de violence est épuisé
en faisant une seule et unique victime, ce
qui est plutôt économique.
Et il n’y a pas que les hommes politiques
qui servent de déversoir à la violence humaine,
pensez aux arbitres de football, par exemple.
René Girard affirme que ce phénomène est
nécessaire parce que la violence émerge
naturellement entre les hommes : comme ils
ne cessent de s’imiter les uns les autres
- leur désir est mimétique - ça fait naître
de la concurrence, de la rivalité qui dégénère
en violence.
S’il n’y avait pas un bouc émissaire
pour tout prendre sur lui - même si, la plupart
du temps, on ne lui a pas demandé son accord
- s’il n’y avait pas de bouc émissaire,
la société serait menacée de dissolution.
Ce qu’il y a de bon dans la haine du président,
c’est qu’elle nous met tous d’accord.
Mettez-vous par exemple à le critiquer, lui
ou le gouvernement, dans une discussion collective,
eh bien il y a 90% de chance que vos interlocuteurs
acquiescent - et peut-être même qu’ils
vont surenchérir, et vous allez acquiescer
à votre tour.
La haine du président, c’est un point commun
qui nous unit, qui crée une véritable communion.
Pour René Girard, le bouc émissaire sert
fondamentalement à préserver et renforcer
l’harmonie de la communauté.
Dans les sociétés anciennes, il pouvait
être littéralement sacrifié, comme en témoigne
les récit mythologiques et les recherches
anthropologiques.
Une fois disparu, il était alors divinisé
- c’est l’origine des religions - et la
collectivité rejouait ponctuellement l’épisode
fondamental de son sacrifice : c’est le
sens des rituels.
Heureusement, le sacrifice n’est pas toujours
consommé, mais seulement simulé.
Dans certaines communautés, pour devenir
chef, il fallait subir un rituel de passage
parfois très violent et de plusieurs jours
qui se terminait par une simulation de mise
à mort.
Pour René Girard, c’est là l’origine
du bizutage : c’est une cérémonie qui
ressoude le groupe en maltraitant un bouc
émissaire.
De nos jours, on peut voir dans tous les rituels
présidentiels (notamment ceux d’intronisation)
des rituels de bouc émissaire.
Ces rituels signifient bien que c’est cet
homme-là qui porte désormais sur ses seules
épaules la responsabilité de la nation,
et leur faste hérité de la monarchie tend
à le diviniser.
Ils sont relativement importants parce qu’on
en escompte ils la ressoudent la nation autour
de la personne président, mi-dieu mi bouc
émissaire.
En résumé, selon la théorie du bouc émissaire
de René Girard, le président contribue à
la cohésion sociale en portant sur lui la
responsabilité des maux collectifs.
Même si la fonction de bouc émissaire du
président était une idée effectivement
défendue par René Girard lui-même, elle
a quand même des limites.
On peut tout d’abord penser que l’animosité
sociale à l’encontre du président, et
de l’homme politique en général, est la
conséquence des promesses non tenues.
Ensuite, la théorie du bouc émissaire tend
à réduire fortement la responsabilité politique
du président ; or, il a quand même du pouvoir,
et comme tout être humain, il commet des
erreurs qui peuvent légitimement lui être
reprochées.
Autre limite, la popularité d’un président
n’est pas unanime dans la population : une
partie en fait peut-être son bouc émissaire,
mais une autre peut être satisfaite de son
action - et beaucoup peuvent être tout simplement
indifférents à son égard.
Enfin bon, l’idée est quand même intéressante,
et je pense pour ma part qu’elle exprime
un phénomène réel.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse de l’idée de René
Girard sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale, voire pour pour lire l'ouvrage
Le bouc émissaire directement, les liens
sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.